and welcome to Hannity and we are
broadcasting tonight live from our
nation's capital right here in the swamp
and the sewer of Washington DC welcome
everybody thank you all for being
here now today is the end of a busy day
for lawmakers with a flurry of votes
including one to possibly censure uh
anti-semitic congresswoman uh to Le a
measure that was killed by democrats and
coming up we'll talk to the newly
elected speaker Mike Johnson Majority
Leader Steve scales many other GOP
lawmakers make no mistake with just
369 days until the 2024 Election House
Republicans and I'm saying to all of you
in this room and all of you that are
watching at home you will s succeed
together or you will fail together there
won't be some winners and some L losers
the only people that will really lose if
you lose are the American people there's
two Slimmer majority uh for divisive
infighting so my message tonight to
lawmakers and we'll disc discuss this
throughout the hour is please put aside
personal grudges individual agendas it
is time the American people need Le
leadership uh These are consequential
times and they need all of you in this
room with me tonight to deliver big on
issues that will improve this country
and in in increase our border security
increase our energy Independence we got
to bring fiscal sanity to the city we
need Law and Order and safety and
security for every American in every
town and every city we need to uphold
the rule of law we need moral Clarity in
this time of terrorism House of
Republicans they can't control what
happens in the US Senate and they
certainly can't force Joe Biden to sign
any bill into law but this is what they
can do they can stop Joe Biden's radical
agenda if they remain United they can
investigate his corruption and they can
shine a bright light on the federal
government's gross abuse of power again
if they stay United they can also Force
Democrats to show their true colors uh
and a series of very important votes put
them on the record they can get
Appropriations done in a timely manner
that are also beneficial to the American
people we've got to stop robbing from
future Generations keep it simple if
House Republicans get lost in the weeds
if they get bogged down with Petty
disagreements if their egos get in the
way voters I predict would punish them
all of you in this room in November 2024
again they will succeed or they will
fail together and by the way the stakes
are very high for every single American
and frankly for the world at this at
this time unfortunately we don't know uh
we how bad things can get under Biden
and one party Democratic rules pretty
bad now record-breaking inflation record
high debt record high gas prices uh
record-breaking illegal immigration
including record numbers of special
interest aliens oh let's see from
countries like IR Iran Syria other
countries in the Middle East of course
China Russia America's enemies around
the world they are embolden and much of
what the world is now you know looking
like it's headed towards War There Is A
Better Way Forward and the house has a
very critical role to play and they are
the last line of defense against the
most radical agenda in the history of
our country and they are a powerful
check on the weaponization of our
government hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else